Russia is announcing this morning it
will take action against the UK by
expelling 23 British embassy staff from
Moscow it is just the latest move in an
escalating dispute between the two
countries triggered by the killing of a
former Russian spy in Britain Elizabeth
Palmer has more from Moscow this morning
Liz good morning good morning high-level
diplomatic rifts follow a predictable
pattern and this one is no different
everybody knew this was coming it was
just a question of whim late this
morning
Britain's ambassador to Russia Laurie
Bristow was summoned to the foreign
ministry starting with the expulsion of
23 British diplomatic personnel from
Russia
it's a tit-for-tat move that mirrors
Britain's expulsion last week of 23
Russian diplomats from the UK after the
British government accused Moscow of
poisoning the Russian exile Sergei
scruple and his daughter Yulia with a
nerve agent Britain's foreign secretary
went even further pointing the finger
directly at Russia's president our
quarrel is with Putin's Kremlin and with
his decision and we think it
overwhelmingly likely that it was his
decision
to direct the use of a nerve agent on
the streets of the UK scribbles
poisoning has forced the police to
reexamine the cases of several Russians
who died or failure on UK soil amid
criticism that Britain's government at
the time shut down the original
investigations for political reasons and
in what seems like a strange coincidence
police now say Nicolai glushko a former
Russian businessman was murdered last
week outside London though they say
there's no link to the script all
poisoning but for obvious reasons
Russian dissidents in London are spooked
it does look as if relations between
Russia and the UK and the UK's allies
including the US are going to get even
worse so this is a bad time for the
thinning of the diplomatic ranks just as
they may most be needed to defuse the
situation
Anthony Elizabeth Palmer in Moscow
thanks Liz